[Music]  helen this species of cartoon has been  extinct since 1998.  i mean these haven't been seen on tv  since the golden era of animation  and what  [Music]  it's it's the warner brothers  [Music]  that's yeah that oh yeah yeah he did it  that that that that that crazy son of a  gun  actually did it clean vectored outlines  wide screen format these don't look like  reruns  uh well uh they're not i reanimated them  we are gonna make a fortune with this  show  how zany are they oh uh uh to the max  of course then there's a pinky in the  brain pinky in the brain  you said you're bringing back pinky in  the brain  say it again we're bringing back pinky  and the brain  put your head between your knees  where are they going home welcome  to animaniacs